what else happened i got rejected by a
woman i don't know if not even the
trucker
i didn't think about that but um a
i hit on a woman and got rejected
uh i'll tell you what happened so you
know i went to this place out here
and we're coming out to you live right
now from the central east out here
and and i went to a locale here
local shop and they sold crepes
crepery and
i don't know what a crepe is but i
didn't care once i saw this lady working
there i said all right
you know i'll eat them until you know
she and i are married if i have to
um they had a girl in there and i saw
her and
you know i made some small talk and it
was
it was awkward because we both had masks
on you know uh
having a mask on
it's kind of like the beginning of like
um shrek or whatever
you know because you don't know how
anybody really
you're not getting the full package
you're just kind of getting that
japanese package of somebody
you know kind of snout up or mid snout
upwards
you know you're kind of getting that um
you know like everybody's kind of a
desert nine
you know when they got that middle
eastern
you know a lot of middle eastern women
they wear the
kind of that word yarmulke whatever it
is that
that muffler you know they wear that
front muffler you can't see them
i was in uh saudi arabia one time at the
airport
and they had a man there and a
fat fella i'll be honest with you really
was and i had
if i could think of another word to
describe him i would use it
but i cannot and this one this man was
what you would call a fat fella
and he uh had about five women with him
all of his wives and they all had on
that um
you know just that little kind of
they're all wearing like a what's behind
door number one kind of curtain right on
their face you know you can't see them
all
so that's called that desert nine you
know where that desert eight everybody's
kind of a desert nine when you can only
see the eyes
so i went in there and i'd seen her and
i like you know was nervous
and anyway you know i went in there and
i went in there a follow-up time because
i'm the kind of guy that'll show up
somewhere
fall in love with a woman that works
behind a counter i don't know if you've
ever done this but i'll
i'll go somewhere fall in love with
somebody who works at the place
and then try and and then go back to the
place
to try and profess my love or make a
connection so
anyway so i go back and i was
nervous and we talked about mma fighting
we talked about adult male you know
uh you know fighting
and so i figured i would try and talk
about that again when i saw her i
couldn't remember her name
and so i was like hey
remember me you know what's your name
and she's like oh my name is
you know clara i believe it was her name
and
so then i was like oh
uh have you been watching any of the
fights
and she said no i haven't and then
i was like so you ever like are so
nervous like you can't even hear what
the other person is saying
you're just like oh have you ever
watched any of the fights and you just
you can't even
no matter what their answer is your next
question
is gonna be something like do you have a
boyfriend
you know uh so she said i don't know
what she said
she might have who knows she could have
been calling the police
but i was like go do you you know have
um maybe we should watch the fight
sometime
and and that was kind of weird because i
didn't
i don't even know kind of how she
responded if she was like yeah or maybe
or
um and then i was like oh do you have a
boyfriend
and that's how i said it too like do you
have a boyfriend
like i just got so
just i was just strung up you know just
like when you see a rabbit and he's got
one of his legs caught in the uh
in that wire you know do you have a
boyfriend
and that's how i was verbally you know i
was that verbal
kind of hung rabbit and
she said i do and i didn't have a plan
for her having a boyfriend
i did not have my plan was
i i ask her out and she maybe says
yes or no i guess was also
i mean that's probably that's always
that's the biggest option but
i didn't have a plan for when i was
gonna think she says
dude i'm making this story so long so
i was thinking okay i asked her and then
she uh she
says no i don't and then i follow up
with oh well maybe i could take you out
sometime or i could buy you
something that's not a crepe you know or
something just a chill line
well i said you have a boyfriend
and she said yes and so when she said
yes i couldn't
it was it would have been weird for me
to follow up with oh well maybe we
should go out sometime
so i didn't know what to ask her so i
just asked her name again
and i was like oh what was your name so
it just
didn't make it didn't make any sense man
uh
it just didn't make any sense man um
so anyway oh and this was the worst part
then then i had to i'd already ordered
the food so i had to sit there she said
yes i was like oh
what was your name what is your name i
said what is your name
what is your name and she told me her
name again
and then the conversation was just
and then she'd like given me like my
plate and fork and knife that comes with
your food that you order and you just go
sit down at your table and then it comes
out
and i was the only person in there so
now i have to sit and i
this is where i really messed up i sat
facing the counter
i sat facing her at the counter and then
i had to sit there and just eat a crepe
which is the loneliest saddest thing you
can eat as a rejected
man it almost feels like one of those
japanese game shows like oh you lost you
eat the crips you know
and so i'm sitting there just eating
this sad
every bite tasted like this girl did not
like me um
but i did it i did it i went in there
i asked her out i didn't get
she didn't i there was no option
and i asked her name again and then i
sat
and point blank ate a crepe in front of
this woman
very very sad um
very very sad so evening good afternoon
and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one